[Música]
é vou começar contando uma história da
minha infância que me marcou muito é eu
nasci no cerrado
vocês vocês conhecem mas têm uma cidade
encerrado chamado brasília a capital da
esperança
ela foi construída com a proposta que
não existiriam classes assistiram uma
mistura passe e fiquei brincando na
infância no cerrado um monte de criança
tive uma infância muito rica uma
liberdade incrível
e aí eu assisti a um filme chamado surfe
no havaí
aí eu falei quero ser surfista foi que
existe uma distância enorme do mar né e
não existia a banda natiruts
eu sou surfista do lago paranoá não
existia nessa época mas eu queria ser
surfista
mesmo morando no cerrado e aí
por ironia do destino
meu pai ele teve que ser remanejado do
emprego dele e aí ele fez uma coisa
muito bacana pra pra minha vida pra
minha família ele abriu um mapa do
brasil e falou família eu meu irmão
minha mulher não quer dizer que o meu
irmão minha mãe eu tinha 10 anos é
decidirmos qual o lugar que a família
morar e aí ele já sabia com a cabeça
dele já sabia que era rio de janeiro
porque é toda a vida social dele foi no
rio de janeiro
apontamos dentro do rio de janeiro é pra
cá e aí ele tinha uma coisa com a ilha
do governador ele gostava muito da ilha
do governador
era uma interesse dele morar e aí abriu
outro mapa o mapa do rio de janeiro e
apontou que vocês acham da ilha do
governador
fale pronto realizei meu sonho no fim da
vai vai morar numa ilha cara
o dia seguinte cheguei na escola dos
meus amigos da escola foi meu amigo eu
vou morar na ilha casa na ilha do sul da
bahia
quando eu cheguei a família mudanças
cheguei na ilha
a primeira coisa que eu fiz porque saí
correndo para a praia da bica
não sei se vocês conhecem a praia da
bica mas fica é cercada pelas águas da
baía de guanabara
saí correndo como um amigo vamos para a
praia vamos parar
e aí o lodo foi entrando entrando meu
pai entrou no lodo e quando eu senti o
chão eu falei algo errado aqui o cinema
me enganou
a saída não é bem aí é que eu vi no
filme então essa experiência me formou
como biólogo queria entender por que
isso acontecia porque que a natureza era
degradada eo porquê que o cinema me
enganou
eu quiser eu fiquei muito chateado com
aquela história e aí então eu comecei
minha trajetória e eu vou dividir a
minha fala com os amigos que eu fiz aqui
em macaé e no brasil está ocorrendo esse
aqui ó
a venda de cozinha tiro que está dentro
isso aqui é muito forte
esse aqui é facultar esse aqui o condor
e terminei a minas no mundo é igual só
com a maré seca e tem o sururu criticava
também na areia submeteu song tem tudo
dizendo que nós não mandamos lhe batia
natureza não podemos ir à caça dos
animais como vocês vão fazer isso agora
e não seja nem ele nem vítima morreu
tocou pra fazer porque tem que ser
justamente onde os animais são eu sei
que todos julgavam ter um animal mas vai
prejudicar esses animais lindos por
causa de um porto que com certeza vai
trazer popularidade para a cidade de
macaé mas vai trazer mudo muito prejuízo
para os animais com vocês de carinho e
até a minha casa de vocês mas esperei
tanto dinheiro mais importante e agora
com essa alteração da natureza sofre a
futura geração que não viu uma
verdadeira natureza
o maior sonho meu era poder mostrar para
a geração futura e atual a natureza que
eu conheci agora imagina o filho do meu
filho
a natureza está morrendo
rosa professor corre professor godoy
professor roy black professor mei foi 20
pela mesma formiga onça juro
opá de barra
ah bom é dessa forma fui atravessar a
baía de guanabara
pra ir pro ferry j estudar fazer
biologia da ufrj uma instituição que
tenho muito orgulho tenho muita
felicidade de ter estudado lá na
biologia eu comecei a perceber é que a
biologia não estava dando conta a
universidade não estava dando conta
existiam caixas que me que também
estavam empreendendo só que na ufrj a
gente tem uma possibilidade de fazer
disciplinas e outros cursos
então eu comecei a perceber isso e fiz
várias disciplinas da comunicação na
antropologia na geografia e dessa forma
eu fui ampliando a minha forma de
entender o conhecimento e aí eu comecei
a fazer algumas leituras são processos
da ciência e tinha acesso alguns
pensadores começaram a me mostrar
algumas falhas do percurso da ciência
dita moderna
a primeira é essa fragmentação do
conhecimento natural social eu queria
entender a biologia social eu queria não
só entender biologia mas em que ele
entender a biologia do cotidiano razão e
emoção corpo mente essas fragmentações
colocar isso dentro de caixas também não
fazia o menor sentido pra mim ea outra
coisa então isso o que são as
disciplinas não só a disciplina mas
também disciplina o conhecimento é um
ódio é um conhecimento disciplinador que
forma o peso que deixa as pessoas dóceis
apagadas a práticas
então essa é uma crítica ea segunda
crítica é a questão de um de um
conhecimento hierárquico como se o saber
científico fosse um saber mais
mais potente então eu não ficava muito
com esse questionamento de alguns
pensadores me ajudavam
então eu comecei a formular uma pergunta
como formar biólogos
eu queria me informar nesse sentido e
depois quando entrei pra dentro da
universidade é nesse caminho que eu sigo
como formar biólogos em fragmentar o
conhecimento e promovendo o diálogo de
saberes
essa é uma questão que eu venho
trabalhando e o cinema me permite isso
porque você sai das caixas que as
instituições colocam e você começa a
experimentar algo de maneira coletiva
então eu tive a oportunidade e quando o
professor de escola pública aqui macaé é
experimentar a produção audiovisual com
crianças
esse foi uma experiência incrível e eu
trabalhei cinco anos de uma escola mas
primeira escola integral na cidade que
ela não existe mais uma escola que tinha
um currículo totalmente diferenciado e
acabou e agora a gente escuta falar de
uma base nacional comum curricular como
esse currículo fosse comum para todas as
escolas
então a diversidade das escolas ela
precisa ser valorizado e aí eu acredito
muito nessa possibilidade de cinema e aí
o que que um biólogo faz né
pior vai fazer filme vou fazer filme
primeira coisa que o biólogo vai fazer
então é seguir os animais afinal os
animais à natureza então seguindo a
formiga eu encontrei uma paisagem linda
dessa uma diversidade de pessoas é e
aqui uma sala de aula o processo de
fazer filme pra mim e pro grupo que
trabalha no laboratório é um processo do
caso de educação
isso aqui é difícil você identificar
quem é um professor que é um professor
que não existe o a figura do professor
existe aqui
o mediador aquele que está no meio
àquele que está circulando o professor
pode ser a criança que está ali as
crianças do agomar ensinou muito elas
que pegaram a formiga onça
aqui você tem alunos de mestrado e
doutorado a alunos de graduação guarda
municipal professor da rede todo mundo
misturado se encontraram para fazer um
filme
o filme do encontro dessas pessoas aqui
um outro outra imagem que mostra quem é
o professor
o pescador ele está na figura de um
professor
então você conversar com essas pessoas é
você ter acesso a outros saberes que
a universidade não dá conta são os
saberes são chamadas tradicionais
saberes locais é e essa é uma outra
experiência que eu tive recentemente um
filme de ficção
então existe uma fronteira entre a
ficção eo documentário filme de ficção e
filmes documentários é essa aqui uma
imagem de baixo
em curaçá bahia eu fui tive uma
experiência de ficar um tempo fazendo um
filme com essas pessoas é então existe
parece que existem fronteiras do
conhecimento caixas certo nessas
fronteiras
elas precisam ser arrebentados ou
precisamos olhar para essas fronteiras
aqui um exemplo de uma fronteira que é
um espaço onde eu venho experimentando
as minhas produções
essa imagem é muito simbólico porque ela
mostra a fronteira de uma unidade de
conservação é uma área protegida é onde
a biologia deixa de ser biologia se
torna política econômica científica a
biologia da vida real e uma mão pensando
eu entro não entro eu arrebento essa
fronteira onu arrebento e aí às vezes é
necessário passar por baixo dela passar
por baixo das fronteiras e passando por
baixo a gente encontra pessoas
maravilhosas como o capitão do mato é
assim que ele se chama de carapebus
ele foi escoltado por de cana trabalhou
durante um período e carapebus né nós
temos uma usina de cana central e ele
foi um trabalhador braçal que é produzir
um açúcar que a adoçar chá de madame da
europa conversar com ele me mostra muito
da biologia me mostra muito do
conhecimento que essa pessoa tem e com
uma biologia pode ser enriquecida quando
a gente tem a oportunidade de conversar
com essas pessoas é essa figura mostra o
processo de fazer filmes de maneira
coletiva
então existe
a pré produção que é escolher um
personagem por exemplo o capitão do mato
ou um personagem como este aqui que está
com a mão na boca ele está escolhendo a
cena aquele é um professor de artes do
município ele está escolhendo como vai
ser o filme existe um processo dialógico
ali do início ao fim
nessa figura aqui do lado é a montagem
do filme isso dentro da universidade
então quem participou do filme está
dentro da universidade está construindo
de maneira coletiva e depois um dos
momentos mais ricos que a exibição na
comunidade é exibir aquele material e aí
você tem um retorno feedback muito
interessante e novamente as fronteiras
da universidade são arrebentados abertas
pra fechar eu queria contar essa
história aqui que é uma história muito
interessante
triste nós é interessante que a gente
precisa saber vocês já viram a ararinha
azul ararinha azul mas que só existe só
existia agora só existe na europa ela só
existe uma comunidade chamada curaçá
interior da bahia e todos os exemplares
foram levados pra europa recentemente
então foi considerado extinto na
natureza não existe mais a natureza
existe um projeto grande para fazer o
retorno dessas espécies na natureza
se não tiver uma parceria com a
comunidade local essa espécie não vai
conseguir voltar para a natureza
ela é uma pedra preciosa azul da cor da
turmalina paraíba que é um outra riqueza
que também é tá sendo bastante explorada
no nordeste pra enfeitar madame que vai
pro acho que a ganhar seus suas
premiações no tapete vermelho
as nossas riquezas
elas são levadas mas não só as nossas
riquezas são levadas mas a nossa mente
também
então existe um processo de colonização
do nosso pensamento é fazer cinema
efe descolonizar o pensamento fazer
cinema com o povo é disponibilizar o
pensamento
fazer cinema é pensar nossa realidade a
partir dos nossos olhos porque senão a
gente vai ficar vendo a partir dos olhos
dos outros e você se tratar de frente
para a televisão e ficar passando um
filme do netflix escolhendo achando que
você pode escolher no filme não que é um
engano porque existem pessoas que
escolhem os filmes que estão ali você
não tá escondendo nada
você está sendo escolhido então eu
convido vocês para fazer cinema com
muito amor e muito carinho um abraço de
schumi à esq
[Música]